[Music]
all right good afternoon welcome
everyone to security 300 stocks gonna be
about how Google's infrastructure helps
enable us to quickly respond to
incidents like things like meltdown
inspector I'm Brandon Baker I'm tech
lead for cloud security at Google I'm
responsible for the security of our
cloud infrastructure and of the security
of the services that we run on top of
cloud I'll be co-presenting today with
Andy che hi everyone I'm Andy Chang when
the product managers on Google security
team and so we're very excited to be
able to share with you how Google's
security architecture and infrastructure
including the technology the people in
process allow us to address at scale
instance of this type weather they're at
the scale and severity of something like
spectre and meltdown which were
fundamental flaws that were found in
most microprocessors today and which
impacted the entire industry or whether
in another example there are a targeted
attack on a specific Google service in
both cases the infrastructure security
design that we have has enabled us to
respond to these and mitigate these
without any impact to customers and
without any effort from customers so
today what we'll cover is really set up
in five stages I'll talk about the
overview of Google's security approach
I'll also talk and highlight some of the
key technologies and then turn it over
to Brandon to go deep on both Spector
and meltdown and we'll take a trip in
the Wayback Machine back to 2014 and
talk about an app engine breakout
attempt will then close with a summary
of really the different things that are
in play across technology processing
people which again enable us to respond
to these things without impacting
customers and without any effort from
customers so first to emphasize that in
both of these incidents these were
mitigated by Google and Google teams
without actually any impact on customers
their data or on google or google's data
and so no data was harmed in the
creation of these events so at Google we
really think about security in five
pillars and we focus product design
technology people and process around
these five pillars the first of these is
really around platform trust the core
technologies and that really that we
create to drive security protection
monitoring identification within the
platform and this will be the focus of
most of the technology pieces of this
talk in addition we have technology and
products focused around the full
lifecycle of data not just in data
protection so collection discovery
consent access protection wipe out take
out that full lifecycle in addition we
also have technology focused around
policy and control and identity and
access management to allow us first to
specify what we think is the proper
behavior and then to detect and enforce
on those behaviors as well as for us to
have your identity be a key thing that
defines what you have access to and what
you authorize on in addition we have a
fourth pillar focused around application
security so that's really around the
different pieces that allow both the
applications we build as well as the
applications you build on our platform
to stay secure again from both a
visibility controllability protection
detection standpoint and then lastly the
fifth pillar that we focus and build
process technology and people skills
around is around our operations in risk
management how do we actually operate
the platform and how do we operate the
infrastructure that you guys develop on
for success and for security the bulk of
this talk will be focused on really
three of these the platform trust pieces
and underlying technologies form the
majority of how we address both the
spectre and meltdown incidents as well
as the attempted app engine breakout in
addition to application security and
then the people and process and
operations for those of you who have
attended previous Google talks at next
or other talks around our infrastructure
this diagram is probably fairly familiar
with you we think about the security
stack at Google really in nine layers
and the core philosophy
Google has always been defense-in-depth
at scale by default in other talks
previously we've gone through each of
these nine layers and the thing to take
home today from this is that both
horizontally within a layer we have
multiple layers of protections so that
there's no single point of failure and
then across each stack layer as you go
up and down the stack we have multiple
layers again that prevents you from
having one single point of failure for
this talk we're gonna focus on really
three areas first around our harp and
Arden hypervisor and the curated OS
images in addition we're gonna talk
about live migration as one of the key
ways we did at scale patching and then
finally we're going to talk about how
both from a process and technology
standpoint our teams do instant response
forensics as well as the sandboxing
technology that per debt Privett
protects a lot of our applications for
the balance this talk will be again as I
said focused on technology processing
people so those color codes you'll see
those in the upper left-hand of each
slide as when it's relevant so to focus
in on that and this that will be true
for all three of the main topics
recovering as a preview of some of the
things Brandon's going in much more
detail about we will be talking about
our purpose-built hypervisor operating
system and the application pieces around
really the containerization that's core
to a lot of how we deliver services as I
think Dianne talked about in the keynote
and really the consistency and
homogeneity of our underlying
infrastructure which enables the next
two items right the ability for us to do
live migration the Vilia for us to do
continuous patching we'll also be
talking about sandboxing technology in
general that we apply to provide
multiple boundaries of security for
applications as well as our G Weiser
sandbox which we open sourced back in
May you know as I think Dianne
highlighted in the keynote Google loves
containers we run a lot of things within
containers including our VMs including
everything in GCP containers really give
us that abstraction boundary and
importantly an isolation boundary for
resources
4/6 akyuu ssin also for us to kind of
manage quality of services and CPUs to
give you a kind of sense of context
around this when you run a service on
GCP you're really running a service
within a container that's running on a
guest OS that's within another container
that runs on our host OS as I think we
highlighted in the morning again on a
weekly basis we start over four billion
in containers so with that I'm going to
transition over to Brandon she's gonna
talk to you a lot more in depth about
both the two instance that we're talking
about today thank you Andy so how many
of you here remember hearing about
Spector meltdown back in January right
it's pretty fundamental discovery and
what made it so interesting so unique
was that you know side channels as a
vulnerability class had been known for a
while like there was research in the
early 2000s that said look if you have a
crypto algorithm and it accesses memory
in a certain pattern based on bits being
in a key you could use that to derive
information about that program's
behavior what was different with
spectrum meltdown was a realization that
the modern CPUs most modern CPUs are
constantly running a speculative engine
another set of programs basically that
you don't have control over which are
racing ahead and trying to fetch memory
that might be useful to the real program
when it gets to around later and it'll
do things like try to speculate and
estimate which branches might get taken
and what an interesting memory then is
useful to try to pull in and it's this
speculative behavior that turns out
actually leaks a lot of information a
lot more than anyone really realized so
much so actually that you can read out
the entire contents of memory from an
unprivileged domain whether it be a user
space process or a virtual machine and
what this had is the potential for an
impact to affect how viens could isolate
be isolated from each other or how a
process could be isolated from its
operating system or have a JavaScript
applicants run in so with this discovery
in mind I want to take you through a
little bit of sort of an inside look of
what this looked like at Google in
responding to this with
focus around cloud but also realization
that this affected and impacted the
entire industry
so we'll start kind of the wayback
machine here back to June last summer
when project zero discovered this issue
there was a period of time then we
transition from July timeframe where
with this as a discovery in a
realization how are we going to fix this
how could we actually respond to this
right this is a fairly fundamental flaw
in modern CPUs that we all depend on we
needed to respond though because the
potential impact in industry was too
great but we also had to develop
mitigations
and workarounds in such a way that
didn't really impact performance that
was a very important element to all the
consideration I think you were doing in
this timeframe you know did the fix have
to come from microcode did have to come
from hardware did it have to come from
software were there things we could do
in the compiler you know this is sort of
this time frame where a lot of experts
from a wide variety of disciplines and
fields came together and spent the time
to think through this and I'll talk a
little bit more about sort of what those
mitigations were and why they're
effective and how we got those out into
production because deployment obviously
is a very serious consideration right
this was a set of flaws that we had to
basically patch every machine at Google
to address and then it sort of moves
forward to this last period of time
frame for disclosure right coordinated
responsible disclosure super important
given the wide impact of this affecting
the entire industry and not to say as we
were going through this time frame every
day every week was always this concern
around it was this gonna be leaked was
somebody gonna also co-discoverer this
there was a security researcher in July
who made a really really close discovery
of something very similar to this set of
problems but couldn't quite get the
implementation details working and quite
right and so you know there was a brief
kind of okay you can pause and get back
into this because it was important that
we also made sure that not just Google
but the whole industry was ready to go
when when it was time to announce this
is she and as part of that you know
thinking through this timeline of okay
where is the world where are people
thinking about
side channel attacks speculative
execution how much interest is there
going on you know is there awareness of
this issue kind of thinking through this
trend and amazingly we were actually
able sort of keep this as a coordinated
disclosure and really it wasn't until
January 3rd when when this actually came
to light mostly to plan so when I talk
about some of the details kind of a
refresher or made me sort of a deeper
dive into how this thing actually works
and what the variants were there are
many variants of this class because in
some sense this is a new class of
vulnerabilities and at the time sort of
the June discoveries of last year the
ones we were dealing with responding to
these were the three variants that we
were looking at and I want to call these
out to you because each one required a
different mitigation and a different
part of our stack so the the first
variant here is something we call bounds
checks by paths I mentioned there's that
speculative engine that's always sort of
racing ahead it skips a lot of important
checks things that normal software when
it actually really does finally execute
will do for example check within the
bounds arrays or within limits or
greater than less than checks those are
checks that the speculative engine
simply doesn't bother with because it's
just trying to race ahead and be useful
to fetch as much memory and as I can
ahead of time well it turns out that
that's actually a pretty useful thing
then to then find interesting code
gadgets where you can induce the
speculative engine to race ahead read
and touch a bunch of memory and then
affect the subsequent behavior of the
speculative engine and it's that
chaining of those events that actually
leaks information the second variant
branch target injection this is also
another behavior that the speculative
engine does when it encounters a branch
it has to decide okay what's most likely
to happen here am I most likely to
expect the branch would be taken or not
taken and it turns out you actually can
either find or introduce or inject
interesting branch target again sort of
gadgets into the address space of the
thing you want to try to leak
information out say it's the kernel
or a hypervisor and use those to sort of
again watch and steer that behavior
watch the pattern of memory that's
accessed and then from your own domain
time how your memory accesses work and
that actually again ends up leaking bits
of information at a time repeat that a
few million billion times and you've
read out the memory of the machine in
the last category meltdown given a
slightly different name given that it's
behavior is a little bit different right
I mentioned these other ones are more
sort of a speculative behavior and
branching and sort of touching memory
meltdown was different in that it's
basically just a fundamental privilege
check that the speculative pipeline
doesn't bother to do until it's all done
with speculation right and this is the
user kernel supervisor page table bit
and what this means is actually the
speculative engine when you're in a user
mode process will happily go and read
right on through into kernel memory in
the same address space something that's
normally prohibited and would generate a
page fault speculative engine doesn't
check that bit until the very very end
of speculation again on some processors
and again what that means as you can
effectively then induce the speculative
engine to read memory that your program
should never not normally be able to
read time access patterns leak
information out okay so with the ideas
here of these these issues I'm going to
take a step back for a moment and talk a
little bit about our our infrastructure
stack and some of the security
philosophy that we have at Google one of
our fundamental guiding principles
really here at Google is a two boundary
a two security boundary rule and what
that means is that we always want to
ensure an engineer into our systems at
least two distinct security boundaries
such that no one single flaw can allow
malicious code hostile code to break out
and in the case for Google compute
engine which underpins a lot of our
cloud infrastructure including
kubernetes engine and and many other
things
those two boundaries happen to be these
two pieces of software here KVM and vmm
are purpose-built
VMM I'll talk a little bit about what
each of those are and kind of how they
compose in this stack and what the
security properties of them are and then
how and where we had to apply these
mitigations
on top of them all right so what is KVM
KVM is the hypervisor that's part of the
Linux kernel this is what the majority
of our con infrastructure is based on
and it's open source
Google's invested quite a lot into
finding and fixing vulnerabilities in
KVM and getting those vulnerabilities
patched and pushed upstream we've also
invested a significant amount in
reducing the attack surface in KVM
reducing complexity taking devices out
of KVM into the host kernel and pushing
them up into user space where they can
be further and better sandboxed in that
user space vmm and so the investment
here is to ensure this is a primary
security boundary is as hardened and is
minimized as possible but yet still
something like Spectre means that if
there is a vulnerable branch target
inside of KVM a virtual machine could
potentially read the memory of the
entire host machine it's a significant
concern and then up in this user space
portion is a purpose-built virtual
machine manager that Google built and
why we went into this approach what we
wanted something it was really small an
attack surface we wanted something that
was built for security from the ground
up applying all of Google's best
security practices and tooling to it and
we also wanted to further be able to
sandbox this thing itself right to make
it an even stronger security boundary
there's one of these user space VMs for
every virtual machine that runs on the
system and each one of these is itself
isolated sandboxed so the idea is if you
think about this multiple boundary type
philosophy if a workload were to break
you out and compromise its vmm that vmm
itself is further sandboxed and
unprivileged and wouldn't actually give
them any additional information without
some subsequent second vulnerability in
the host itself okay but again something
like say meltdown
well now mid mean if somebody were in
the vmm they could read through the
meltdown vulnerability all the memory of
the host including all the memory the
other virtual machines in the platform
that simply won't do so we have to
and think about a series of mitigations
here okay so what were those mitigations
the first one was something that we
developed an engineer and the kernel
team at Google Paul Turner developed
called Rhett Pauline we'll talk about
that in detail in a minute but really
the point I want to emphasize here is it
was our familiarity with KVM the fact
that we spent so much time doing
vulnerability discovery and fixing and
attack surface reduction in KVM that
allowed us to know exactly the right
places in KVM that we needed to patch
and apply the spread Pauline fix to
address and mitigate that specter
variant you that applied to the
hypervisor likewise mentioned meltdown
there's a mitigation there we also had
applied kpti it's a kernel page table
isolation I'll talk about that in detail
here in the next couple slides but this
required not only for us to update the
operating system on our host machines
Linux but also to coordinate across the
industry working with all operating
system vendors to get all OS images
patched with this type of technology and
then also there was that variant one
that bounds check overflow that meant
going and essentially working with the
compiler team working with the operating
system team and looking for those
vulnerable gadgets to exercise them and
remove them Hey so to go a little bit
deeper here even more into rep clean
what rep Pauline was was a realization
that looked the speculative engine
that's racing ahead and trying to figure
out where things are gonna go and
potentially then it could start leaking
bits based on branch movement of the
speculative engine we actually could
trick that we actually could trap it
into essentially an infinite loop that
would grab that speculative engine and
basically make it realize well it it
there's actually really no interesting
branch here at all for to speculate past
and essentially trap it in and then when
it came time to actually really execute
past this branch we could self modify a
little bit of that code and then open up
that and the real execution when the
real instructions were issued would
actually then go past and go beyond it
so it's this captive behavior that
actually is what makes this rep clean
invention work
the other nice property about this is it
has very little impact in performance
right
we can't just we don't want to just turn
off speculation across the board because
the performance of most modern CPUs
would be impacted dramatically but we
can do is we can very selectively
surgically insert this into those
vulnerable branch points and ensure that
the speculative engine will leak
information across those shifting back
over to this editing kernel page table
isolation kpti this is some technology
that was derived from Keyser research
into essentially you can think of this
as what we've been doing for many years
is having a single page table for both
user space and kernel addresses okay and
what that meant is that if you were in
user space normally if you try to
address the kernel memory high memory
above a certain address there'd be a
page fault I can't do that right the
page table entry says well this part of
the memory addresses for user space this
part is for privilege for supervisor for
the kernel and the problem is that
meltdown just blows right past that so
we had to do is go ahead and take the
hit to say okay well we've been doing
the single page table strategy and
operating systems for decades for
performance reasons because whenever you
switch page tables you have to flush all
the past translations start over from
scratch and if you're switching back and
forth between user and kernel that's
really inefficient really slows things
down but conveniently a few years back
modern CPU started to introduce this
idea of a tag TLB this is a way to
divide up that translation buffer so
that you can have essentially
translations remain in the buffer
between different page tables well now
rather than switching from one page
table to another page table having to
flush everything and rebuild all those
translations again really slow process I
actually get to leave them in the in the
TLB
and then when I switch address based
address space I just switch back and
forth between those translations they
they remain resident and I don't have to
flush them out so now now with this in
place then I can split up my page tables
and that means now that user mode can't
actually meltdown through to any other
addresses other than its own because
there are no kernel translations
available to it it actually has to take
the full transition which stops the
meltdown problem and again thanks to
this tag tlb pc ID is one particular
implementation in the processor context
ID feature really speeds things up again
there's also ended up having minimal
performance impact so I just talked
about the things that we did to patch on
the host right this platform this
infrastructure was also important to
make sure that the operating systems
that run on top of this infrastructure
inside these VMs themselves were also
patched and so this was very much a kind
of industry everyone having to work
together to have this ready to go in
time for the announcement right when it
became public and this is a
collaboration collaboration that is
driven by very experienced vulnerability
responders at Google and connections and
through the rest of the industry so now
I've talked about this then how do we
actually then get this out in production
and in particular get this out in
production before the world knew about
it without actually sort of tipping off
what was going on okay so this is
another technology that we have at
Google underlying Google compute engine
called live migration live migration
technology and many virtualization
platforms including KVM and our
purpose-built vmm that allow you to move
the entire contents of one virtual
machine from one physical host over to
another and importantly do so without
actually disrupting the workload you
don't have to restart the operating
system you don't have to restart the
workload you don't even have to
reconnect existing sessions okay um
quick overview of kind of how this works
you know you take a virtual machine you
start to copy all of its memory over to
another physical hosting machine and
essentially you're trying to
reconstitute that vm over there
so eventually over time you get all the
memory copied over but there's always
constant memory churn because the VMS
are left running the entire time you're
doing this but eventually in time you
get most of the memory states seem to
cross and there's a short blackout
period where you have to pause this
virtual machine get the last little bit
of memory and CPU state and device state
moved over to the other reconstitution
version of that virtual machine
restarted over there
restore all the network connections and
then let it go again and we're able to
do this in just an order of milliseconds
operation with very minimal impact or
really no noticeable work workload
impact at all and in fact this is a
process this is a system that we apply
and we do regularly at Google to patch
the host operating system to patch the
VM em to apply micro code updates to the
host machine and so as a process of
doing this we're able to essentially
move all the workloads off of a physical
machine patch that host machine for
whatever needs to be done for servicing
or for security reasons restart that
move vm's back and essentially just
shuffle through an entire zone within
GCE and roll out these patches these
updates again without the workloads
being impacted our customers really even
being aware that this is happening
amazingly then what this in place is we
were able to apply these patches in the
host for specter meltdown over the
course of the month of December without
anyone noticing
and not just for GC you actually did
this across the entire Google fleet to
make sure things like Gmail and G suite
and search and Docs and everything else
also had all these patches in place it's
kind of interesting to think about like
a system that starts and runs four
billion containers a week was able to be
patched for these issues without anyone
noticing or realizing it was happening
over the course of a month I've talked
about the technology that made this
possible but also took people right took
people in process as well the way that
we often operate with Google is sort of
as a volunteer firefighter
type model right where there's a major
issue okay we have to do something about
this let's pull together people that are
experts in their field whether it be
compilers or virtualization or operating
systems or CPU design as well as cross
discipline right requires communication
and coordination and response and
marketing PR everyone has to come
together to make this actually work and
and this is not the only time we do this
we do this quite regularly right that
I'm talking about one particular
incident here I'll talk about another in
just a minute
but essentially I would say that you
know it's this relationship
connections that we have that really
make this process work and the end
result is as I mentioned we were able to
patch Google for Spectre meltdown
without anyone being affected and
without anyone realizing it was
happening and this is a proven process
one that essentially we've established
now can this work against this new class
of vulnerability I specter meltdown type
things and it's one that we've proven in
production if you want to read more
information about the actual details go
far more detail it's been an hour
talking about each one of these
different variants alone got the links
here to the more information about that
definitely recommend reading that and
now I'm gonna transition to talk about
another interesting incident right that
happened this was the 2014 App Engine
attempted freakout
we talked a little bit about kind of
against some how this technology applied
and helped manage and mitigate this also
a little bit kind of what it looked like
from the inside and then how all of our
process and people everything come
together so quick background some
context here in 2014 a security
researcher Adam did Iraq expert in
finding issues with the Java Virtual
Machine right finding ways for Java code
to break out of its its sandbox
started to actively do research on
Google App Engine all right so you know
what is App Engine App Engine is a
managed application platform that allows
users to deploy code to Google whether
it's PHP Python go Java we take in host
stats and you have to think about the
actual infrastructure underneath that
well that Java part is interesting to a
Java security researcher and he wanted
to understand just how strong that Java
boundary was and in fact well we sandbox
as I mentioned before to make sure that
the attack surface is reduced to make
sure the layer underneath whatever the
thing is that we rely on a sandbox is is
tightly locked down but again I
mentioned the two boundary rule so
whereas the Java VM was a boundary in
the system maybe wasn't the only
boundary and so
kind of walking through the sequence of
what happened and what this looked like
the researcher poking around the
platform trying to look at how we were
structuring how things were done where
the boundaries were whether his
experience and knowledge and Java would
apply here as well
started to poke concerta to poke what
that looked like from our point of view
is on December 5th we saw a lot of
interesting alerts and a lot of things
took to light up like somebody's
actually doing something very active
against the platform something some
somewhere maybe where they shouldn't
necessarily be we didn't know who it was
what they were doing why they were doing
this but we definitely knew something
was serious major issue so we froze
those instances we suspended the account
to look at this understanding exactly
what was going on and so what was going
on is yeah we were depending on the Java
Virtual Machine as a first security
boundary and App Engine right we were
relying on that to constrain the
behavior of the programs that were
deployed so they couldn't do things like
issue arbitrary system calls or run
arbitrary binaries on the hosts and we'd
gone through and done a lot of
meticulous work in the java vm itself to
sort of reduce that attack surface and
apply these restrictions but it wasn't
something that the Java VM was actually
really originally ever designed for and
so it was a process that we had to sort
of apply and add on to these things and
the security researcher was finding
weaknesses and flaws in that boundary
what it highlighted to us is the
challenge the issues around relying on
the Java VM as a security boundary and
helped to motivate the development of
stronger sandboxing technology at Google
but the other thing that was happening
here and this was the interesting part
is the next day so December 6 the
security researcher went on to the full
discloser
security mailing list and said hey
everybody I've been doing research on
Google App Engine I think I may have
poked a little bit too far and gotten a
little too aggressive because I got shut
down I got detected and shut down right
away and that was the moment and that
was actually the point at which we
realized ok well actually now we know
who was doing this and what their
motivation was maybe they should come
and talk to us maybe we should work
together and dealing fixing these
vulnerable
because what they actually had done is
they broken out of one sandbox but they
had landed it right back into another
sandbox and a sandbox that wasn't Java
right two distinct different types of
sandbox is different technologies
different skill sets different
vulnerabilities required to get through
but it was a place where we could
monitor and see very anomalous behavior
to spawn respond and and and shut that
down and that moves into new technology
and new sandbox and technology that we
developed something called G visor g'
visor is sandbox technology that was
derived from research into operating
system-level virtualization right we
think of virtualization we usually think
either really low-level like machine VMs
right emulating CPU and device behavior
or we think about these language level
vm's like java the idea with g visor is
actually there's a maybe more even more
efficient way to sandbox and isolate
applications by emulating system call
behavior and so essentially we're
emulating an operating system not a
machine not a language but an OS at the
system call layer and in fact with the
development of this now we're able to
run the majority of untrusted code at
Google on top of G visor and it's
significantly more efficient than trying
to fall back to running everything into
a large virtual machines we open-source
that this earlier this year if you're
interested to learn more about G visor
we have an entire talk on that coming on
Thursday I definitely recommend going to
take a look at that's or go up onto
github and you can take a look at the
source code for it so the end result is
with this series of technology and our
Incident Response process and the multi
layers of sandboxing we were able to
detect and constrain and confine and
attempted break out of app engine by a
noted security expert the other thing
about this is in doing so in such a way
that they were still confined didn't
impact anybody didn't impact other
customers or other user data the other
thing that this leads into is the
vulnerability rewards program at Google
and why this interaction and outreach
with security researchers is so
important we ended up developing this
relationship with the security
researcher and to find and fix more
issue
with an app engine so that customers and
users could be safe to talk a little bit
more about the vulnerability rewards
program and I hand it back over to Andy
thanks brandy
so as Brandon alluded to the bullet
really was reward program was something
that once we had the connection with its
career researcher we were able to pull
them into that and engage with them of
that and kind of to step back a bit the
purpose of the vulnerability rewards
program at Google is really around
turning what is traditionally an
adversarial relationship between
security researchers and software
developers and software providers into
something that's collaborative and
creates value and wins for the security
researcher themselves so the software
provider and really most importantly for
the end customer as security researchers
get rewarded both in terms of
recognition and actual financial
compensation for their energy for the
ingenuity for their interest in digging
into things deeply and us as software
providers get the benefit of that
additional set of eyes working actively
to improve and find flaws in the
software and as I said again and
customers benefit because the quality of
software goes up the thrombi rewards
program at Google was started in 2010
over eight years ago and today we've
paid out almost 12 million dollars and
rewards to that so in addition to the
recognition and some folks do this for
recognition some folks do this to
security researchers do this to just
improve underlying software and some do
do it for the benefits of the financial
award but as we as we look at it it
really promotes things like ethical
hacking and over the time as the program
is evolved we've expanded the program to
cover not just Google and cloud but
Android and other services at Google
each have out their own parts of the
real mobility rewards program also as
times evolved we've continued to
increase also the financial wards tied
to particular vulnerabilities that are
found just recently we elevated the
reward found for sandbox escapes from
$20,000 to 31,000 three hundred and
thirty seven dollars and if you want to
know where that number comes from you
can talk to me
after this session so once we're able to
bring this together security researcher
and therefore able to really understand
what was going on and resolve the
incident both we were able to then go
mitigate the issues on App Engine and
then proceed forward and start looking
for the next incident you know to talk a
little bit about that we've talked about
in Brandon's covered a lot of the
technologies process and people around
specter and meltdown and in both Spector
and meltdown and the 2014 app engine
breakout the overall process of how we
do detection response at Google was the
same so Joe as an overview we have
experts in socks around the world that
follow the clock on a 24/7 basis from an
overall standpoint when we think about
the problem of detection response we
actually break it into two parts first
is a underlying pre fail component so
how do we proactively understand how to
assess our own attack surface our own
potential risks and vulnerabilities
whether things they've been done to
specify using policy the things the
behavior that should be how do we
actually build protections like we
talked about on the two boundary rule
the sandbox thing that can currently
build a structure that's difficult for
the aggressors to get through and in a
lot of ways the two boundary rule the
defense in depth
is trying to flip the story really from
a case where traditionally attackers
have the benefit right they're hiding
within a number of signals as a defender
there's a needle and haystack problem
trying to find them in the midst of
everything and flipping this in a multi
boundary situation to where the attacker
has to be really careful because they
have multiple layers they actually have
to get through and try to escape
detection and that's trying to balance
out that attacker
defender relationship in addition to the
pre fail pieces and the protections we
then obviously have monitoring logging
which allow us to both understand if the
pre fail configurations and
specifications we've had drift as well
as to handle the post fail case to
actually detect
there is an actual incident and as
Brandon outlined before we the two
examples go to the rest of the process
to bring in that volunteer firefighter
approach bring in experts around the
different aspects of Google to address
these things and when we think about the
post fail detection response process is
also multistage right there's the
process of detection itself and the
signals database that we built out to be
able to do this
the alerting the actual response itself
which can be either straightforward or
significantly complex when something's
at the scale inspector and melt down and
then communications communications
internally communications to the product
teams communications to customers
communications to other entities that
are involved in the situation
and ultimately for us the learning
feedback so both at a human level a
process level and also machine learning
technology level so they were better and
so that each step each next thing we can
further reduce that time to detection
and further release the time the
mitigation so our security teams had the
benefit of very integrated forensic set
of tools whether it's to do live memory
forensics or disk forensics timeline
analysis and tie all these different
threads together and also the automation
to do that at scale we've actually open
sourced a number of these tools so that
our customers in the community in
general can benefit folks of you who are
in the industry are probably familiar
with juror
turbine iya recall is there a number of
the tools we use every day time sketch
which are all now available on get as
open source tooling that you can use
yourself to also build out your
forensics toolkit and one of the other
things is as probably you would it might
anticipate Google is one of the most
targeted sites across the world so from
that benefit our security teams have to
be ever vigilant and there's the classic
problem of garrison fatigue if you're
vigilant for on standing on guard for an
extended period of time and don't get
many actual incidents or pieces with
these those systems are protecting us
how do you still retain that vigilance
so we have an active culture within
Google of Red Team
of Google on Google and that's a key
thing and again these are the same
philosophy we use in our instant
response it's a volunteer firefighter
approach so we get some of the key
experts to go hack sometimes and attack
their own code other folks code within
the products and that kind of both
energy and spirit as well as that really
putting the highest-level expertise and
visibility on particular types of red
teams enables us ourselves to quickly
find vulnerabilities and flaws in the
system so we don't play out the VRP for
our own internal employees too much of
their unhappiness so if you look at the
kind of overall threat detection
pipeline once we see something you see
that cycle of looking at logs observing
then actually orienting in terms of
figuring out from a security analytics
what's going on actually making
decisions about like from the underlying
pieces what to do and ultimately taking
those radiations the top part of that is
technology and process centric so we
have the advantage of large scale data
ingestion pipelines threat detection
pipelines some of those things you guys
have seen as a part of Google cloud
platform bigquery is something that we
use internally as well to do a lot of
our signals and logs processing and then
from the ingestion standpoint the
ability to really take in and handle all
that scale data the last point I want to
re-emphasize what Brandon talked about
as well as you can have the greatest
technology you can have the greatest
process you also need really really
strong people in this space we're very
fortunate to advantage of a lot of
experienced folks in this space as I
think you've heard throughout this talk
I've given all the different aspects of
some of these vulnerabilities especially
something like Spectre and melt down the
vault multidisciplinary nature of the
skill set needed readily available
in-house at Google to address things
whether it's processor architecture
compilers OS virtualization
you know underlying Hardware all those
pieces can come together and then an
equally important thing is as one of the
largest targets also one of the biggest
contributors to security
or the community we have tier 1
relationships to with other similarly
skilled organizations and entities and
that allows us to be in the loop for a
lot of these discussions so as I
mentioned previously the stock that we
use is 24/7 around the world and the
underlying teams really occluded not
only the subject matter experts but the
mix of security engineers analysts and
also forensics experts and so the bottom
half of this loop then is really around
the human aspect of it top half beam
technology and process we also need the
humans to actually make the decisions
the right decisions as Brandon talked
about where to put mitigations like
reptilian and where to actually do those
with lowest impact overall performance
so to summarize now given something at
the scale of Spectre and meltdown which
again were fundamental flaws in most
modern microprocessors that impacted the
entire industry for someone who is a
Google customer it was a non-event
customers didn't have to do anything
customers were not impacted and that
really is kind of the nature of some of
the security though and it design
infrastructure that we put in place and
the con going aspiration of how the team
works and then just to summarize then as
we've talked about through this in order
to achieve that type of result we really
do need proven technology process and
people and it starts with the core
philosophy rig around Google that
Brandon I both talked about this
defense-in-depth no single point of
failure that at least two boundary rule
built across all the services and all
the components within Google where we
are very fortunate to have that ability
to have an end-to-end ownership of
hardware the software many of things
purpose-built so then also that deep
understanding of the underlying
technology so to know where to put
mitigations and fixes where they have
the highest impact on the actual
security instance and the lowest impact
on end customer performance as I think
Diane highlighted in the keynote the
consistency of our infrastructure
homogeneity
the kind of ability for really us to
manage our infrastructure in the
commonly used phrase as cattles not bets
so that you can have automation
scalability and you can do patching
detection all these at scale and then
really the proven response and
remediation process at the end of the
day that experience multidisciplinary
team so we designed the solutions that
addressed the flaws found inspector and
meltdown so that they could be mitigated
across all of Google and for all of
Google's customers we applied patches to
the full fleet of Google including GCE
in one single month before these attacks
were public with again no effort from
customers and no noticeable impact on
them so with that I'd like to conclude
the talk and then him back up so it can
take some questions I think there's a
floor mic at the end if you guys have
any questions
[Music]